first though we can talk to the
conservative mp
steve baker the deputy chairman of the
south styled coveted recovery group
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning
mr baker so this week boris johnson is
expected to be pushing through
the six months extension of the
coronavirus act which does things like
give the police more powers
how are you going to be voting and why
well i expect to vote against but
the thing is with so many vulnerable
people now vaccinated and record
progress being made
people will be right to ask why the
government is still seeking to hang on
to these powers to put it in context
under schedule 21
of the act there's been a 100 record of
unlawful prosecutions 246 people
unlawfully prosecuted the act makes
provision to for example postpone
elections
but we're not postponing elections this
year so the government does need to
answer why
as so many people are vaccinated then
not
relaxing restrictions in line with that
data so this easter for example
it will be unlawful to stay away from
home
and it will be unlawful to stay away
from home with another
household until the middle of may so
it we need to be really careful here
that the police don't end up in another
invidious position where they're
enforcing laws we've put in place
to the surprise of politicians who they
then seem to feign shock
that the public have been for example
turn around on our motorways and send
home the big fine
um you're talking there about the
politicians failing
shock about the actions of the police i
mean people would also be thinking about
the sarah everard vigil
do you think the police should be taking
responsibility for
in some cases perhaps being too
heavy-handed or do you put blame at
the foot of politicians i think we
politicians have got to take the blame
here the police
obviously sometimes do make mistakes and
there have been instances which i
wouldn't defend like using drones
to pursue people um but and clearly it's
difficult to see how it was a wise
decision to break up
the vigil but that's not really the
point the point is the police are being
put in an invidious position
as the police federation have said as
dame cressida dick has said
we give them the law we expect them to
apply the law we expect them to apply
equally to all and we shouldn't be
surprised when they do so
so of course there are occasions when
the police unfortunately
perhaps go too far but you can't blame
them when we've passed
uh well rather we powers have been used
under 118 acts of parliament to cope
with coronavirus so it's an extremely
complex legal environment something
we've talked about before
on your show and the police have my
sympathy and uh
it's we politicians and the government
in particular of course
who control the business of the house of
commons who need to justify every power
they take
and every power that they seek to hold
on to particularly whilst they're also
quite rightly boasting of the
great progress we're making on
vaccinating people
you say that you're expecting to vote
against uh when this comes before the
house of commons next week how big
a rebellion do you think we could see
it's very difficult to say until we've
seen the exact
detail of what the government's uh
tabling and how the votes will come
but let's be absolutely clear because it
seems that labour and the snp
will vote for any old authoritarianism
these days it looks like the government
will of course
get their business with an enormous
majority but i do think it's important
that some of us do seek to hold
the government to account with these
extraordinary powers it's obviously a
very uncomfortable position for some of
us to be in when it's our own party and
that's why we're trying to do it in a
civilized way
asking reasonable questions but the
government will get its way
and at this stage i wouldn't like to say
how big any rebellion will be
of course the plan out of these
restrictions
is a path to freedom it's just it
unfortunately we believe many of us
believe that it squanders the advantages
of our great vaccination program so it's
difficult to see how
very many people will want to vote
against a path to freedom
but we'll need to look at exactly the
detail but the coronavirus act itself
i am expecting to vote squarely against
i think it's excessive and
disproportionate and the government
itself now isn't using its powers and
where the police gain powers in the act
as i've said it's a
100 unlawful prosecution rate so i think
the coronavirus act should now go
that would not put the furlough scheme
at risk we've double checked that and
had it confirmed by the house of commons
library
so obviously there's a lot to look at
this week but the government really does
need to start
taking advantage of their own great
success on the vaccination program
at the same time though lots of people
listening to you will be thinking the
one lesson of the last year
is that this virus is extremely
unpredictable
yes the vaccination program has been a
success so far but we're aware of supply
issues
bubbling up over the next month it is
unpredictable
they say that they want to lift
restrictions by june and get us back to
normal but again
we don't know when things like new
variants for example could rear their
heads is it not
sensible for the government in those
circumstances to
extend the act well it's sensible for
the government to take proportionate
powers
remember the civil contingencies act has
far greater provision for scrutiny by
parliament
when extraordinary powers are taken and
so one of the problems we've got here is
in our panic and in
in our sort of blindness to all other
factors we've ended up with the
government taking extraordinary powers
with very limited parliamentary scrutiny
and we would not normally have approved
such a thing
so really what i'm saying is to the
government they really should now
start looking at dramatically reducing
the range of powers that they have
making sure that the law is clear to the
public and that the government has taken
responsibility for that law so that the
police aren't in an invidious position
but yes of course this is a tricky
situation but
the chief medical officers have been
very clear with us that the the vaccines
are expected to still protect people
from hospitalization and death even with
the variance you know that that is a
subject
over which we've gone many times we know
that most of the protection comes from
the first dose the second dose is about
longevity
that was a joint letter from the chief
medical officers so
people on my side of the argument are
trying very careful trying very hard to
carefully base
our arguments on what we're being told
by scientists
there's a bit of a live debate among mps
and among everyone really
about holidays about whether summer
holidays should be permitted to try and
open up the travel industry
or if actually because our vaccination
program may be
speeding along while others is a bit
more sluggish it would be more sensible
to press the pause button on overseas
travel
what's your position i think with
overseas travel there's a very good case
to
to look at it and say that actually
because of the situation in other
countries the government's got to take a
very careful view
but what an extraordinary situation it
isn't that you can't leave the country
freely i mean these are powers whatever
the government's decision whatever the
advice is these are powers which should
be taken
with great trepidation and regular
parliamentary scrutiny so i
do think in relation to international
travel i do think it's inevitable
with the situation where it is with
other countries vaccination programs
being
in such a different place i do think
it's inevitable that a different
approach will be taken to the one
domestically but i think we've got to be
sensible and proportionate on all sides
of this argument
but yeah i mean i do expect that if our
vaccination program is proceeding at
pace
and people are safe because they're
vaccinated then they should be able to
travel
but equally i hope you won't mind and i
think your viewers would expect me to
reserve my position a little to actually
look at the data
as it emerges uh yeah that's definitely
fair enough uh steve baker thank you
very much for being on the program uh
this morning always good to talk
you're very welcome thank you